in order to understand my next move you
need to understand the core fundamental
concept of king and pawn end games which
is what we're going to be learning about
today king and pawn end games are so
complicated that it would be impossible
to fit everything into one video but
today i'm going to be showcasing some of
the core fundamentals and we'll be able
to expand upon those in future videos in
king and pawn end games you will always
have one of two goals you are either
trying to be faster than your opponent
so promoting a pawn faster or getting
your king to an active square faster
than your opponent or you are trying to
zugzwung your opponent and if you
understand that you will have a good
time with king and pawn end games i'm
going to say that again because it's
really important in king and pawnee
names you will always be trying to be
faster than your opponent or zouzong
your opponent most of you guys know
about opposition and opposition is
actually a critical form of zug's wong
which is one of the reasons why
opposition is so important in king and
pawn end games understanding opposition
distant opposition diagonal opposition
all types of opposition the better you
understand opposition the better you
will perform in king and pawn end games
if we can get a meaningful zooks wong on
our opponent we will be able to win the
game the problem is we have to look at
the second half of king and pawn the
pawns if any pawns can be moving freely
this is called reserve tempi because if
you get the opposition but your opponent
has a reserve tempi they can use that
reserve tempi and now your opponent has
the opposition this brings us to the
main two principles about reserve tempi
the first always hold on to your reserve
tempe for as long as possible and the
second always try to deprive your
opponent of as much reserve tempe as
possible knowing those two principles
can you find white's only drawing move
here pause the video right now if you'd
like to try to figure it out or simply
enjoy the show because here white has to
play f5 disallowing his opponent from
playing g6 and keeping in reserve too
tempi for his h pawn now even though the
a pawn is lost king takes a4 king c4
king a3 king c3 a4 white has just enough
reserve tempe to keep black's king
trapped on the edge of the board and
draw this position if this h pawn was on
h5 then black would win this position
because white would be zug's long tier
white would have to force the black king
to escape and obviously this would be
losing for white but here white can keep
the black king trapped with h4 and after
king a2 king c2 a3
now h5 king a1 king c1 and the game is
drawn if a2 then king c2 it's a
stalemate if king a2 then simply king c2
and eventually you will repeat so
knowing what you know about reserve
tempe what move should black play in
this position black started with g4 and
this position is still actually drawn
after king to e3 but this brings me to
another endgame principle which is very
important to know which is sometimes you
can make a small mistake and the result
of the position will not change but if
you keep making enough small mistakes
then eventually one of those small
mistakes will change the result of the
position you'll either get a draw from a
winning position or a loss from a
drawing position and that's also one
thing you have to keep in mind when
you're trying to press drawn end games
if you're in a drawn position many times
you should not be expecting your
opponent to just make a huge blunder
that throws away the game you should be
trying to induce many small mistakes
from your opponent and eventually one of
those small mistakes will change the
result of the game once again this
position is still drawn but since black
has played accurately with g4 white must
now respond accurately with king to e3
the move played in the game king c3 was
a losing move white has no reserve tempe
but black has won and eventually black
will be able to sneak their king in
here if black did not have any reserve
tempi the king would be forced back the
white king would come to d4 it would be
an easy draw but black can play h5 white
must be forced to one side of the board
black will infiltrate pick up some pawns
and win the game in this position white
is actually slightly better both sides
have three reserved tempe on the king
side but white has this additional tempe
on the queen side which black does not
have access to if black ever plays a4
white will be able to capture this pawn
create a past b pawn and win with that
however of course white is able to play
a4 the winning plan for white is to
advance this king and pawn and
eventually infiltrate on the e5 square
the other thing you have to notice in
order to identify that plane is that
king e4 is not a threat if king c3 king
e4 we can simply play king c4 eventually
we will get our king to d5 and promote
this pawn in the game however white did
not realize this they must have made
some miscalculation about king e4
because in the game white played a4 now
the game is drawn after king d6 king c4
king e6 d5 check king d7 not king d6
because after king d4 eventually black
is the one that is zoo zwang black
starts with king d7 king d4 king d6 and
now white must move after running out of
all of the pawn moves white must still
make a move here and the game is easily
drawn since white will never be able to
infiltrate on e5 king c4 king d7 king d3
king e7 the game is drawn white's win
started with king c3 and now with king
e6 king c4 king d6 d5 king d7 king d4
king d6 we have this position again but
white has an additional reserve tempo
with a4 zoox wanging black the pawn
moves will eventually run out h4 h5 f3
black must move white infiltrates e5 and
wins the game black is up a pawn in this
next position but are we able to win it
first we must stop the white king from
getting to c4 so we do so with king b5
white wants to get their king to c4 so
they start with a4 check we must concede
the c4 square we play king b6 king c4
and now a5 white has no better move here
than to play d6 which allows king c6 and
after d7 king takes d7 king takes c5 we
have this position where black is still
up upon but white's pawns are further
advanced and white's king is much more
active it's very important to realize
something here which is that black
always has this idea of playing h5 and
making a past pawn however in order for
that to be effective we have to be able
to stop white's past h pawn realizing
those two things we know that if black's
king is ever inside this red box here
they'll be in time to stop the h pawn
and so if black's king is ever inside
this red box white's king must be inside
this blue box this is the start of the
winning idea we play king e8 and after
king d5 king e7 black is trying to push
white back and eventually infiltrate
their position and capture the base of
their pawn chain if king d4 simply king
d6 and black has gained the opposition
black will be able to infiltrate so
white tried king e4 instead the idea
being after king d6 white can play king
d4 and white has opposition now what is
black doing until you remember that
black has this reserve tempo h6 black
regains the opposition and will win this
game going back to this position i want
to take a look at a cute line that you
may have calculated based on the second
position that we looked at today here
you might try something like this king
c7 king b5 king d6 with the idea that if
king takes a5 we now trap white's king
on the side of the board now king a6
king c6 a5 we have this waiting move of
h6 king a7 king c7 a6 you may think that
black is out of waiting moves so what is
black to do until black plays h5 the
idea being that you can allow white to
take this you play g4 h6 g3 h7 g2 h8
g1 equals queen and since the king is on
h7 this is now check
and black gets this very cute staircase
maneuver with their queen
checking all the way down the board the
f pawn blocks the e4 square king a7
queen c5 check and eventually the
checkmate on a6 very very cute from
black unfortunately this calculation
does not work for black because white
can play king a8 if you advance your h
pawn or capture white will play a7 and
now black must stalemate white otherwise
they're going to be getting a queen and
if you play the even worse move king c8
well you forgot that white can take your
pawn with g takes h5 white will actually
win this game knowing what you know now
about king and pawn in games and reserve
tempe see if you can find the move that
i played in this position the answer is
i played rook h5 because this is forcing
my opponent to either play f6 and if we
ever trade into a king and pawning game
my opponent no longer has that reserve
tempi or they have to play rook g6
adopting a very very passive position
for their rook and i would be very happy
with this in the game my opponent played
f6 and we drew the game not too long
after this i hope you enjoyed my lesson
about some of the core fundamentals of
king and pawn end games thank you very
much for watching be sure to check out
my youtube channel and like the video if
you enjoyed thank you very much and i'll
see you next time